hey 42 here ever since humans invented
the wheel
we have been obsessed with speed for
thousands of years we have been
designing and engineering vehicles and
techniques to help us move faster
we eventually invented the car which
allows us to travel anywhere at speeds
of up to a few hundred kilometers per
hour
we then quickly realized that this was a
grave mistake because all I did was
allow us to get to work faster so we
invented even faster aeroplanes so we
can instead go sit on a sunny beach
somewhere sipping a piña colada but this
incessant pursuit of speed has come with
some strange side effects namely the
sonic boom at sea level sound travels at
three hundred and forty point to nine
meters per second which is pretty darn
fast but in 1947 some bloke called Chuck
Yeager he was an American test pilot and
speed obsessed lunatic managed to travel
faster than that at four hundred and
twenty-eight meters per second and break
the sound barrier for the very first
time using a bell x-1 aircraft witnesses
heard an extremely loud boom and saw
something quite strange a cone-like
object emanating from the aircraft this
will come to be known as the sonic boom
but what is a sonic boom and what causes
it let's find out
sound travels as a way with crests and
troughs if you were to visualize sound
waves they would look like spheres
emanating from the source of the sound
with each ring representing a crest of
the sound wave the crest of the sound
wave appear almost perfectly symmetrical
when the object emitting the sound is
stationary however when it starts to
move something peculiar happens the
spherical sound wave crests that are
travelling in the same direction as the
object get squashed together and each
wave reaches the observer quicker than
the previous wave yeah I know that can
be a bit tricky to wrap your head around
but basically when an object moves sound
gets squashed the results of this sound
wave compression is an increase in the
frequency of the sound this means the
sound becomes higher pitched as the
object comes closer to you this is why
cars approaching you sound higher
pitched and when they're driving away
from you think of it like putting a big
burly bloke on a fast roller coaster his
voice may sound deep and full of
confidence when he straps himself into
that seat but start that baby up and he
starts squealing like I was working ok
that's not totally caused by sound wave
compression what would general dislike
for roller coasters but you get the
point
on the flip side however wave crests
that are being emitted in the opposite
direction to which the object is
traveling take longer to reach your ears
so you hear the noise at a lower pitch
this is known as the Doppler effect but
why I know for my telling you about all
of this how does it relate to a sonic
boom well it's extremely important to
understand the Doppler effect because a
sonic boom is created by exploiting the
Doppler effect take a high-speed
aircraft for example as it travels
through the air it is constantly
emitting sound waves just like any other
sound emitting object these waves
radiate from the source in a spherical
fashion the sound coming from a jet is
mostly a mix of engine noise and air
resistance as it pushes air molecules
out of the way at very high speeds the
latter is what is responsible for that
whooshing
you hear as an aircraft passes overhead
the sound waves being emitted in front
of the aircraft are being compressed the
faster the aircraft is traveling the
closer together these waves get was as
long as the vehicles velocity is not
higher than 340 point two nine meters
per second that's the speed of sound the
wave will never touch each other or
overlap because each wave is traveling
fast enough so it can get out of the way
before the next wave is emitted but what
happens when you travel faster than the
speed of sound and don't allow each wave
enough time to propagate outwards before
the next wave is emitted this is where
things start to get funky when the
aircraft exceeds the speed of sound each
sound wave is released ahead of the
previous wave because the object that is
emitting the weight is traveling faster
than the waves themselves
this causes the ways to get pushed
together and create a single sound wave
with an enormous amount of energy called
a shock wave if we could see this effect
in real life the sound waves would
appear as a cone trailing behind the
aircraft this is known as a mock cope in
the field of aeronautics the speed at
which sound travels is known as Mach one
the result of this extreme compression
of sound waves is a very deep audible
boom which we refer to as a sonic boom
any observer watching the aircraft pass
by wouldn't actually hear the sonic boom
until the very tail of the Mach cone
reaches their ears however the pilot as
well as any passengers aboard the
aircraft wouldn't hear the sonic boom at
all because they are traveling faster
than the actual sound of the boom so the
sound will never catch up to the
aircraft and will never reach their ears
they can sit comfortably in their cabins
sitting lattes whilst traveling faster
than the speed of sound in relative
silence
Amba noted the fact that their deafening
every pore saw that they pass below
contrary to popular belief a sonic boom
doesn't just happen once as an object
breaks the sound barrier the Mach cone
and the sound of the sonic boom are
present for the entire time that the
object is traveling faster than the
speed of sound
for as long as the aircraft is traveling
at this speed the beam remains a
constant noise that follows the aircraft
around so that explains the sound but
what about the visual effect of a sonic
boom what causes that weird cone-shaped
object to appear behind the aircraft
when it breaks the sound barrier this is
caused by a rapid change in air pressure
which is caused by the high velocity of
the aircraft this drop in air pressure
causes the temperature in the atmosphere
behind the aircraft to drop
significantly causing condensation in
the air so what you're actually seeing
is water vapor in the air undergoing
rapid condensation but this is not
actually directly related to breaking
the sound barrier condensation clouds
from aircraft can be seen it's a whole
range of velocities these condensation
clouds don't always come inside with a
sonic boom whether you see this
phenomenon or not depends on many
factors such as the humidity of the
atmosphere and the air temperature it's
not just high speed aircraft that can
produce sonic booms ur sonic booms are
found in many places in both nature and
the man-made world when you crack a
bullwhip the cracking sound is not
caused by the whip hitting itself the
noise you hear is actually a tiny sonic
boom created as the velocity of the whip
surpasses the sound barrier the pistol
shrimp is also capable of creating a
sonic boom this tiny little booger is
like the Chuck Norris of the ocean it
can snap its claws together so fast and
it creates a sonic boom between its
claws this sound is so loud that it can
stun or even kill over sea creatures
that's basically like being able to kill
someone by clapping your hands for
goodness sake nature calm down that's
just a ridiculous amount of power to
give to a shrimp but it does go to show
anything we can do with technology
Nature has probably already beaten us to
it
fine to the V subscribe for more 42